okay so a basic
strategy is to never play to his
strengths
so avoid his strengths
capitalize upon yours okay
and some strengths are
people tend to just practice those
things and so
it's almost synonymous with don't play
to their strengths
is think outside their box okay
so he takes his stance and you can see
he's got some futuristic skills do you
see that
so just kind of culturally go down
boxing kickboxing muay thai
do you get it so don't play those games
okay um so
some of the things you want to take
advantage of for example
boxes are not used to defending their
legs
to attack the legs a lot of people that
wear gloves
they can't grab so they're not used to
grabbing and having things grab because
the mit
the glove's in the way closing it
and then uh strikes to the back of the
head
a lot of times illegal okay so they're
not defending
the back of their head okay so
we'll combine this strategy
with working on transitional flow and
getting my
range okay and then we'll combine it
with
slipping the jabs so we still want to
stress inoculate ourselves so that we i
can see the strikes
especially the strikes that hit me okay
i have to be willing to see the strike
that hits me
before i learn how to get out of the way
okay
so you're going to head in this stress
inoculation drill
right for his jab he gets to practice
good
rage okay and we'll have him throw it to
the forehead so it's not gonna bust your
nose or anything
but my goal is to look at it and slip
that thing
at the last second so i don't want to go
like this and stop
i want to test myself i don't have to
right race in but i'm going to go
forward
constantly and move off do you see how
i'm doing that okay so that's my drill
so i'm going to move out and he's going
to bring his jab back
like three drills in a row one
pop and boom take that down okay
boom i'm gonna have to come back to get
the pull and adjust and get the kick
down
remember when you kick down you're not
scoring a point so
you want to make sure that your shin is
going down to the ground so his leg is
going down to the ground
and kick through the target
as if your shin was going to hit that
ground
off won't pop okay and just so you're
not beating up again
take something okay
okay let's try it's a little a little
more dynamic boom she's gonna dance out
and i'm gonna pop that
that grip down the boom
and i'm gonna kick everything's to get
more percussive
so now
i'm going to drop this here attack that
ankle
drop right there
or he pulls out like that okay
so he's he's used to that
so i'm not going to throw that one okay
so i came in
pull up boom
over this way okay back in the head with
that
looping back now okay
all right boom and drop that thing in
there then i'm kicking
on the inside of this leg
i'm doing this
boom i step inside is that kick over
there
okay let's try okay so these kicks are
i'm going to call them displacing
kicks and they're different from
when you learn bad habits in your karate
you're
just trying to cause pain what you're
trying to do is
deconstruct so
i have a line here and there's a hinge
there
so i'm going to displace that kick that
hinge with my leg get that thing to move
but along the inside it's the same thing
he's got a structure
i'm gonna i'm gonna move that thing i'm
not trying to
kick it or injure it i'm trying to move
he doesn't have his face okay so on the
first one
i was taking it down okay
but it's a displacing down it's not
a pain impact or an injury it's a
mechanical displacement boom so this
one make you well your foot this is how
most people land
and this is what you're talking about
but for training
don't give them that and then you don't
take it
but on the second one as i move
my whole body again is going to it's
going to hit
um if i try doesn't get it my whole body
is coming in and hitting this way not
not just a point
my whole body is moving that way
but i'm hitting that mask the whole body
and that gives me the inside and then
his place so he's in this white base
okay
and now you can do more things because
he has to recover his balance
okay displacing go
okay so that would work off that grab so
he's coming
in boom and i'm gonna move uh with
uh not pulling on this
okay in other words so when he goes to
grab
yeah you move forward by your pulling
knife the trick
is is as you feel him go you just move
it
into it okay so it goes dead on him
he should feel like he just grabbed air
so
whoa
oh so
neutralize pull
and then your strike hits the back of
the head
here okay
neutralize boom
neutral boom
neutralize bloom then turn the head
turn the hat
okay